boom
I'm your host Alan sake on what's up and
welcome to simulation very excited to be
talking about what the Superbowl says
about humanity's priorities I think this
is a very pressing topic to be talking
about right now we just experienced a
Super Bowl very recently fifty-three and
it's quite interesting to be analyzing
civilizational priorities right now we
have a lot of geopolitical concerns we
have a lot of exponential technology
concerns we have a lot of existential
threat mitigation that's occurring and
we are just extremely consumed with
things like the Super Bowl and things
like advertisements telling us to buy
and obey and I think this is coming at a
pressing time I'm excited to talk about
this and to try and inspire people to be
bigger critical thinkers about exactly
what is being pushed on to them by
cultural stereotypes and it's time to
push into more of a counterculture
mentality in a very interesting nuanced
way so we will break that down right
here for you as we go through you will
be seeing some of my notes and some
images and I'll be pulling other things
for my computer along the way so 70,000
people attended this live and this was
held inside of the in Atlanta this is
the mercedes-benz dome inside of Atlanta
70,000 people attended this event and
that's in person and then then a hundred
million people watched it around the
world so this is a massive event a
hundred million people is huge that's a
third of the United States population
and so imagine if we could get a hundred
million people and 70,000 people
attending alive and a hundred million
people watching at home about a
conversation between the United States
and Russia and Chinese leadership about
how to how to be calm and how to prosper
together most ethically we got to get
ourselves out of ethical kindergarten
basically and we're still having this as
one of the greatest events rather than
geopolitical discourse and spiritual
actualization we have a long way to go
so alright so this being once a year as
well so imagine if very little to do
with the future of humanity sir our
priorities in many ways are [ __ ] and
we have to be very vigilant about the
way that we describe these things
because we have to be real with
ourselves that we have to have a
realignment of civilizational priorities
and protocols resource flows frameworks
for flourishing and that that's not
happening right now these discourses the
proper ones aren't happening right now
all right now I want to have some nuance
here because I think this is really
important to highlight that you know
playing sports at high levels is
actually very cool it's it's cool
because I mean I played sports basically
my entire life and a lot of my close
friends played sports their entire life
playing soccer or football or basketball
or tennis or golf or whatever sports it
is across the world there's so many
different unique sports in Southeast
Asia in India and all these other places
as well and what they do is they teach
you a lot volleyball even tennis there's
so many sports and so what what you can
find out for men and women ice skating
all this kind of stuff and what you can
figure out is that there's individual
sports there's team sports but what
happens is you learn how to do things
like you learn hard work you learn
strategy you learn different algorithms
for the game you learn the rules you
learn how to maximize your effectiveness
and your creative potential on the field
you become a peak performer you have to
hustle and work really hard in training
so you can perform well on the field
these are all really important things to
realize about sports and I think it's
very quick that people dismiss sports
that are highly intellectual but I think
there's got to be a better synergy
between the athletics and the Hollywood
scene and entertainers and whatnot with
scientists engineers entrepreneurs
politicians and there's got to be a
better synergy between those two things
better balance and we got to figure that
out together
and as you as you know I mean there were
some really interesting feats of of
athleticism you know at this game here's
you here's where you can see literally
you know you know you're 70,000 people
attending this live I mean this is not
easy stuff to be able to to to be able
to know how to how to how to do serious
work with with being a team player and
knowing how to run routes memorize plays
read things and make split-second you
know millisecond decisions on where to
go and how to properly tackle aim to get
the ball out aim to kick field goal aim
to score touchdowns etc play within the
rules these are all very interesting
things so that's just someone the nuance
I think the nuance is extremely
important this is not a binary topic so
now I want to explain that you know
these sports stadiums as you saw here
earlier they're empty ninety percent of
the time and I talked about this in the
TED talk that I gave TEDx talk in San
Francisco that these stadiums being
empty ninety percent of the time the
sports stadiums around the world being
empty ninety percent time means that we
can fill it with curious and elections
the rest of the time we can fill it with
their already being filled part time
with musicians a very very small
percentage of time but artists
scientists have debates and we can have
these large-scale intellectual
discourses we just have to train adults
and kids to care more about having these
discourses and being more of a creative
mindset wanting to build that out we
also need the proper resource flows and
frameworks to enable people to want to
pursue creativity at more able degrees
because right now we're so caught up in
working 8 to 16 hours a day on things
that we don't even love that it's so
difficult for us to come back home and
be able to what basically sleep and do
some entertaining stuff but we it's so
hard to be able to actually go and spend
time thinking and learning and creating
so that's a completely huge transition
that we need and you know we do see some
of this I want to share some of it here
we see some of it here with with
organizations like intelligence squared
debate Sui like them a lot and they do
this in multi hundred thousand seat
theaters as well
where they're discussing really pressing
topics that civilization needs to focus
on and they're showing both sides of a
conversation and the nuance another one
is called monk debates monk debates is
also very cool again multi hundred even
thousand seat theaters and more and
again on these pressing topics there's
something about the debate format that I
think is really interesting so I'm will
taneous I think we can do better than
the debate format by focusing on
creating knowledge graphs of the
subjects that we're talking about while
we're live talking about them and then
showcasing the nuance of the most
important key points as we go which
simulation is going to be exploring as
we do more interviews and we're gonna be
building out our ability to make
knowledge graphs on every single episode
as we go so that's gonna be really
exciting we're excited for that okay so
this has been a little bit a some
teaching you guys a bit on the
introduction to some of these thoughts
around the Super Bowl around humanity's
priorities but the the again we're
caring we need to care more about
empathy than necessarily about
entertainment at this point we need to
care more about resource flows and
maximizing human potential and we're
we're in many ways we're just too busy
we're too busy to have this nuanced
discourse we talked about it earlier a
little bit and there's too much noise
going on in civilization that's making
it difficult for us to to focus on the
signal and have this discourse so
Hollywood in the entertainment industry
needs to step forward and say hey we're
gonna propel geopolitical nuanced
spiritual discourse and less so on the
more distracting and and numbing and and
and just noisy side of things we need
advance past ethical kindergarten and
realize what's truly important to us and
it was kind of ridiculous because there
was there were there were a bunch of
things that I thought were kind of kind
of ridiculous there was like there was
I'm not I'm not Gus and I'm not gonna
show this stuff either I'm I'm not gonna
show this stuff and I'm not gonna propel
any of the companies that were doing the
advertising either but there's like a
puppy bowl and a kitten bowl but there's
no enlightenment Bowl everything's
upside down in terms of our focuses we
don't need half Nate
women as visual stimulation for the men
as cheerleaders on the sidelines people
are there and the men are there to watch
the game with these women have so much
more creative potential to unleash why
are people fighting at the parade this
was ridiculous it's right here in it was
it was it's a little bit upsetting to
see stuff like this and you know these
are people you know fighting at the
parade and it's upsetting that you know
why are they fighting at the parade and
why are there people you know what
they're with their phones out and like
this the signal so much about
civilization that we're just sitting
here with our phones out videotaping
these people that are fighting against
each other that are for some reason mad
maybe they're intoxicated they just
these are these are things that are
again they're just they're just
upsetting and we have so much more
potential than to be doing things like
that and we have to learn how to help
each other figure out how to help each
other figure out what we can do how we
can help how we can help respect each
other and focus on the big picture on
things and not these these these
quarrels over weird subjects like
whatever they were arguing about and
again I'm not we we we we have a we have
a lot of progress to make you passed
ethical kindergarten in many ways as a
civilization so this is also kind of
ridiculous the for those that don't know
they make the t-shirts and the hats and
all this other merchandise pre-made for
both the Patriots and the Rams the two
teams that were playing in the Super
Bowl
and this gear gets the gear that doesn't
the the winning team keeps the gear
obviously because they won that's us
championship and the losing team the
gear that says the losing teams name
with the word championship of the
champions and stuff on it gets shipped
to places in the world where they need
clothes and because we make it all ahead
of time in it and you know here's here's
you know here's some of the gear from
Earth Rams you know for the Rams
championship shirt which you know you
can purchase but like doesn't make sense
because they didn't win right and this
was all already pre-made and now it's
being distributed out around
the around the world people other people
that need it it's kind of I guess it
provides shirts there's hats and stuff
to people but it's also kind of
ridiculous like all right mm-hmm all
right now let's get to the advertising
obviously this is a pressing aspect of
what is so crucial to discuss about this
because everything in the advertisements
was about buying and obeying buying and
obeying selling you [ __ ] you don't need
paying five million dollars for 30
seconds and nothing about unity nothing
about how to prosper together nothing
about society's pressing issues and
topics hiring millions of dollars in
actors are spent none of them said [ __ ]
that according to what I've seen so far
did anyone turn it down if you guys know
if people had turned it down I'd love
for them to step up and make a unity
commercial I'd love for them to step up
and say hey I declined being a part in
these in like Pepsi's or Pizza Hut's or
whatever commercial and I step I stepped
away from that because I don't want to
be part of that I don't care if they
offer me a million dollars and we have
to keep that ethos assimilation as well
that we're not just gonna start branding
our stuff with coca-cola or whatever
because they come and offer us a million
dollars in McDonald's we have to be very
vigilant about that and so do you this
is why a lot of our politics around the
world get corrupted because lobbyists
come in with big dollars and they say
vote this way and you can't get
corrupted you have to keep your ethics
and your principles grounded and that is
such a hard thing to be able to do and
so we have to carry that ethos with us
and make sure that Millennials and Gen Z
and further carry that style of an ethos
away from the greed and corruption and
more towards the first principle ethical
consideration on things so I'd love to
see again none of these commercials that
anything to do with the unity and so
many millions of dollars were paid and
acting as well for top name actors so
again Pepsi was hiring millions of
dollars in actors to prefer to promote
their sugar drink bubbly was selling
their beverage Colgate was selling you
their toothpaste planters this is
ridiculous they kicked kale chips out
the way so you you know nope do your
kale chips here's nuts instead and it
was you know a Ron and Charlie Sheen and
Doritos had a commercial with their hot
brand with chance the rapper and
Backstreet Boys again millions of
dollars why didn't any of these people
step up and say no I don't want your
money
I want to make a commercial about unity
these guys are already multi
millionaires they can band together and
make a great commercial about unity why
isn't no one that we know working on
that project yet why can't we get
Hollywood to spend 5 million dollars
that's five hundred thousand dollars
times 10 actors and our actresses and
then they can just band together and put
together that unity commercial we can
make that happen we can make that happen
and have a call to action on the unity
platform where people can enter in their
message they can make communities around
how to how to act locally and think
globally we can do this this is this is
this is a pressing issue to get out of
ethical kindergarten so this was also
kind of ridiculous you know Bud Light
was basically [ __ ] on Miller Lite
and Coors Light saying that they have
corn syrup but again they're all
promoting drinking and these brands of
drinking and I mean you can probably say
with its with a decent degree of
confidence that the guys that were
fighting at the parade were probably
somewhat intoxicated like we have to
graduate we have to grow up this is we
have to teach our kids how to grow up we
have to teach our kids about the
priorities of unity and the priorities
of building things of value into the
world and and spiritual actualization in
geopolitical leadership and
collaboration Jeep was selling you their
car strength and then at the end they
were saying you know you want more
mercedes-benz a-class was saying if only
everything happened the way you wanted
it and this was an interesting point
maybe one of the better ads of the
Superbowl was out he saying that they
were gonna transition to a third of
their cars to electric vehicles by 2025
I hope so but again they had this stupid
scene with someone choking on something
and a cubicle during it as well and
cubicles are a major form of of people
not feeling actualized not feeling
respected in many ways and then Google
had an interesting ad where they said
that you know 7% of of you out there are
veterans and you see these numbers and
these numbers relate to you because you
need you know you want jobs you want to
figure out your life when you come back
and veterans are a crucial part of the
people that we respect so much because
they help us maintain a free domestic
and foreign policy and and an an
equilibrium here at home and whatnot and
around the world and so this is a mostly
a good commercial it's also you know
Google has a lot of other things that
they also need to be focusing their time
on as well and promoting their mentality
of don't be evil where is you know where
is that let's talk about that let's talk
about your transparency let's talk about
all your projects that are going on
let's you know let's actually you know
your your massive organization and so as
Facebook and Amazon and Apple and these
companies need to be more transparent
they are now the behemoths of the world
humanities priorities are whack and we
were able to see this at the Super Bowl
Walmart order groceries online picked
them up for free other commercials that
sold Pizza frozen dinner cell phones and
other [ __ ] that's what it was selling
you more [ __ ] I think one of the best
ways for us to move forward is to create
a style of a merge scenario between high
level sports continuing to be
inspirational for us and people getting
to peak performance States playing these
sports they're very exciting there's
things to learn from them totally and
also reprioritizing the way we focus on
global discourse and the trajectory of
civilization there are too many
spectators and democracy democracy is
not a spectator sport but people need
enough time and enough mentorship and
enough guidance with education to be
well-informed people as they vote in a
democracy so we need to figure out how
to best do that and right now we are
totally lacking in that field and that's
what's causing this absolute mayhem
where we have a hundred million people
watching the Superbowl 70,000
while tending it live but we don't have
70,000 live attendees and 100 million
people watching some of the greatest
intellectual spiritual geopolitical
debates of our time we need to have that
transition occur we need to have that
rise up and meet where the Superbowl is
at and have people be able to realize
that hey this is again we need to be
focusing on this more so that's a lot of
the current you know the current
thoughts on on where we are at with with
the Superbowl and Humanities priorities
you know I again I want to show this
image this is this is where we can get
to we can get to these larger scale
global discourse around human bees most
pressing topics we can get people
watching these more get them more
televised to have you know imagine if we
had these you know 16 teams or 32 teams
just like an MBA or an NFL or MLB
etcetera a World Cup style tournament
where intellectuals from different
countries let's say teams of two a man
and a woman from from Israel a man or a
woman from China a man a woman from
South Africa or Libya wherever we're
deciding to step up and try and win on
their continent first on underscore
surround like exponential technology or
uplifting the baseline of humanity and
then they came and they competed on like
a continent by continent level and then
like on a World Cup stage we can make
that happen once a year that can become
a part of civilizations nomenclature and
ethos and just culture but we have to
make a counterculture movement to get
that to become a normal part of culture
and we can do that we can start
highlighting these really pressing
topics so again this is about
civilizations priorities this is about
adjusting civilizations priorities and
we can totally do this but again it's
just we're gonna require the right
counterculture movement and you join us
this is how we do it everyone you know
we don't we don't do this by by sitting
here and just talking about it the show
is about action you know this shows all
about action we we not only feature
people at the cutting edge of knowledge
but then we help you get going we
connect people we build commune
these we get going locally and then we
think globally on how to impact you know
a couple people in our neighborhood then
a couple people around our city then
around our state nationally and around
the world and we got to keep building
things of value into the world like that
and keep working together to get there
so also get talking to your other
friends about this kind of stuff think
critically about the state of humanity
what was the Super Bowl like well why
don't we have that at these bigger
stages talking about humanity's most
pressing issues why don't we have a
World Cup style for intellectual
discourse around the world let's make
that happen
simulation will propel that but we need
your help too from around the world so
let's make that happen everyone and
don't necessarily just look at the way
that you see ads and see how they're
trying to get you to obey and buy you
know put on these these these glasses
that that show you the truth you know
when you look at that when you look at
these advertisements for certain things
you know someone's trying to someone's
trying to sell you something right and
when you put on your eyes you're you're
true these true glasses and you look at
it and you realize oh my gosh they're
actually just trying to sell me crap
they're just trying to tell me to obey
they're just trying to tell me to buy
what I don't need you gotta be
critically thinking like that when you
watch these advertisements they're not
they're propelling unity and global
discourse they're they're trying to sell
you things that you don't actually need
like we really really really gotta have
better discourse about that as well as
they're just better critical thought
about that so much love everyone let's
propel more of these conversations
around the world about critical thought
around humanity's most pressing concerns
and getting people on these bigger
stages um and you know like I said we're
not we're not completely ragging and
tearing down sports we had a very
nuanced conversation about that so they
have their place Hollywood has their
place but there needs to be a greater
synergy with scientists politicians and
engineers around the world with them so
let's make that let's make that happen
let's start the counterculture movement
and propel it forward thanks everyone
for tuning and we greatly appreciate
this has been what the Superbowl says
about humanity's priorities we greatly
appreciate
I'm your host Don sake and this is
simulation vs had a good time give us
your thoughts in the comments below join
the community chat as well we'd love to
hear from you and again go and talk to
other people about this support the
artists and entrepreneurs in your local
communities that you believe in and
around the world that you believe in
support them please support them help
them scale help them increase their
impact
you can join simulation below the links
below as well help us scale our impact
and much love everyone and we will see
you soon peace